das phoenix tagesgespräch heute mit
katrin göring eckardt siehst
fraktionsvorsitzende von bündnis 90/die
grünen und uns zugeschaltet aus
brandenburg einen schönen guten tag
dorthin
guten tag ich grüße sie frau
göring-eckardt die bund länder gespräche
sind zu ende die maßnahmen beschlossen
wie bewerten sie ja zunächst mal ist
glaube ich uns allen klar dass die
situation nach wie vor sehr heikel ist
und das gut was man dass die
ministerpräsidentin die kanzlerin sich
jetzt getroffen haben und nicht erst
zugewartet haben die mutation macht mir
jedenfalls große sorgen wenn ich mir die
maßnahmen anschaue die daher beschlossen
worden sind dann sage ich ja es gibt
gute dinge dabei ich bin sehr froh dass
wir uns durchgesetzt haben bei der
pflicht der arbeitgeber ihn zum thema
home office das muss jetzt umgesetzt
werden in einer verordnung und zwar
übrigens auch so dass es dann
funktioniert und dass es kontrolliert
werden kann ich bin sehr gespannt auf
das was so bertels heil da jetzt vorlegt
werden das ja seit vielen vielen wochen
und vor allem in den letzten tagen
gefordert es gibt aber auch natürlich
dinge wo ich mich frage warum müssen wir
wieder hinterher hängt genauso wie mein
home office auch schon vor ein paar
wochen hätte beschließen können und das
ist die frage der schnelltest
ich glaube dass es wirklich notwendig
wäre und gut für alle beteiligten auch
dafür dass man jedenfalls ein bisschen
normalität zurück bekommt wenn
schnelltest auch solche die man selbst
machen kann tatsächlich überall
ausreichend zur verfügung stehen würden
das gilt für die schulen das gilt für
die kitas sowieso für die pflegeheime
aber natürlich auch für viele andere
arbeitsstätten deswegen bei den
schnelltest muss ich echt sehr viel mehr
bewegen wo schießen die beschlossenen
maßnahmen ihrer einschätzung über das
ziel hinaus oder sind die alle im rahmen
na ja im moment geht es ja darum dass
wir noch nicht wissen ob die mutation
nennen muss man ja sagen schon so stark
in deutschland sind dass sie
möglicherweise eben auch zur weiterer
sehr viel schnellere ausbreitung führen
und insofern finde ich das ist
und alles einigermaßen im rahmen was ich
allerdings auch sagen muss
lange ist über die schulen geredet
worden aber ganz klar muss sein egal was
passiert als erstes müssen die schulen
wieder aufgemacht werden nicht dass wir
wieder so eine situation haben wir jetzt
auch die letzten wochen und tage viele
gehen arbeiten und haben möglicherweise
sogar am arbeitsplatz noch nicht mal den
genügenden schutz oder sind eben nicht
im home-office aber die schulen sind
weitgehend zu es ist für die kinder das
ist für die eltern ein gigantischer
stresstest und es gibt noch zwei weitere
dinge erstens erwarte ich jetzt von der
kultusministerkonferenz dass sie sehr
schnell sagen wie das mit diesem
schuljahr geht wie diejenigen kinder die
es nicht schaffen konnten weil ihre
eltern nicht genug helfen konnten weil
sie die technik nicht zur verfügung
hatten was auch immer wie die mit diesem
schuljahr umgehen können damit sie nicht
noch weiter zurück gesetzt werden und
das andere ist wir brauchen wirklich
dringend eine perspektive und ich bin
nicht diejenigen sie sagt dass wir
müssen ein datum festlegen das ist ja
quatsch sondern wir müssen sagen was
passiert wenn man deutlich unter 100 ist
was passiert wenn man deutlich unter 50
ist was man wenn man deutlich unter 20
ist wenn man eine gemeinsame anstrengung
will der bevölkerung dann reichen nicht
appelle sondern dann muss eben auch klar
sein da kannst du wieder mehr menschen
treffen da kannst du wieder ganz normal
in die schule gehen oder eben auch mit
vier gene konzepten und da haben wir
schon wieder sehr viel mehr an
normalität und diese aussicht mit einem
stufenplan auch wieder raus aus den
beschränkungen die brauchen wir jetzt
dringend wir können nicht immer dieses
alle 14 tage alle drei wochen alle vier
wochen starren alle auf die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
und dann hofft man dass man damit
irgendwie klar kommt die leute sind müde
sie sind gestresst besonders die eltern
mit kindern zu hause oder die inzidenz
ziehen in deutschland sind ja sehr stark
unterschiedlich befürworten sie oder
kritisieren sie dass es so einen
föderalen kurs gibt es also die länder
im grunde genommen beschließen können
naja jetzt machen wir die schulen auf
weil die inzidenz werte niedrig sind in
anderen bundesländern lassen
über noch geschlossen oder wären lieber
ein ein zentralistischer war kurs dass
nach dem motto alle schulen in
deutschland beim zuges mitte februar und
pasta manche fragen und bei sehr hohen
instituts in insgesamt macht es
natürlich sinn gemeinsamen regeln zu
haben und bei sowas wie den masken macht
es auch sinn und es macht natürlich auch
sinn dass die informationen gemeinsam
und zentral passiert wir erleben das ja
häufig dass die leute überhaupt nicht
wissen was gilt jetzt eigentlich genau
bei mir weil sie abends im fernsehen
nachrichten gesehen haben und dann
feststellen wo bei mir zu hause ist es
aber jetzt ganz anders
das ist absurd aber nochmal wenn man
einen stufenplan macht der gekoppelt ist
an die instanzen dann bedeutet das eben
auch man kann unterschiedlich agieren
und gerade was die schulen und kitas
angeht ist es natürlich auch angebracht
das zu tun
es ist übrigens alles immer damit
verbunden dass es in jedem fall eine
betreuungs der anti gibt weil wir haben
der nicht nur menschen die im
krankenhaus arbeiten und im handel
sondern auch andere wo es gar nicht
anders geht als dass kinder auch in so
einer schwierigen situation wie wir sie
jetzt haben die betreuungsgarantie haben
müssen und zwar das wiederum überall hin
dass jetzt alles zu zentralistisch
gesteuert hatte man nicht viel mehr
steuern können über beispielsweise
gewerkschaften sprechen mit
arbeitgeberverbänden hätte man sich doch
auch zum beispiel beim thema home office
viel früher eigentlich ein
schulterschluss gewünscht oder wie sehen
sie ja also ich finde es ein bisschen
mich das stresst mich wiederum weiß ich
nicht sehe dass wir das erreicht haben
was wir erreichen können und es ist ja
klar wir diskutieren seit frühjahr über
home office da waren ist viel mehr
menschen die von zu hause aus gearbeitet
haben
wir haben jetzt schon fast das nächste
frühjahr und die frage ist ja warum sind
eigentlich nicht überall genügend
digitale endgeräte da warum es auch
übrigens nicht nur bei unternehmerinnen
und unternehmern dass es nicht passiert
sondern auch in vielen behörden menschen
nach wie vor am arbeitsplatz sitzen und
deswegen alle versuche sich dazu einigen
haben dazu geführt dass diejenigen die
sowieso willens sind und alles
ermöglicht haben dass auch weiterhin gut
gemacht haben und das war übrigens eine
mehrheit aber bei vielen
anderen ist es eben nicht passiert und
dass da geht es nicht nur darum dass
leute nicht ins home office durften
sondern auch darum dass der
arbeitsschutz am arbeitsplatz überhaupt
nicht gewährleistet ist wenn dann zig
leute in einem großraumbüro sitzen und
dann auch noch ohne mund nasen schutz
ohne masken dann ist es wirklich auch
eine gefährdung der gesundheit und
deswegen auch sehr ich mein recht auf
home office ganz grundsätzlich wünsche
jetzt geht es hier um arbeitsschutz und
deswegen gibt es so eine verordnung
hoffentlich sehr schnell damit wir auch
sehr schnell handeln können meint katrin
göring eckardt ist fraktionsvorsitzende
von bündnis 90/die grünen ich sage
vielen dank für dieses gespräch und
ihnen einen guten tag ich bedanke mich
auch alles gute für sie
dankeschön